ich habe keinen ts server ich habe
keinen minecraft server ich habe keinen
dies kein dass das dieser server dieser
kontrapunkt zu der gehört nicht mir
selbst verlegen welchen leuten einfach
meinen namen benutzt haben meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einem
video auf einem server der angeblich mir
gehören sollte also ich gehe mal eben
hier von runter und gehe auf die ip
kontrapunkt eu da könnt ihr wollt
vielleicht auch bald aufgehen ich weiß
nicht ob es ein crack server ist keine
ahnung ich habe mein kreft gekauft von
daher keine ahnung gehe hier drauf und
wenn ich jetzt hier was schreibe
schreibt jetzt ein punkt um punkt ihr
seht da skype ebikon crafter punkt um
punkt und ich habe vorhin schon etwas in
chat geschrieben das sieht man jetzt
natürlich nicht mehr weit vom server
runter gegangen bin
contractor der name ist jetzt nick
blacklist okay mein name ist nicht
blacklist ich weiß nicht was die mir
sagen wollen allerdings ist es ein
server der über meinen namen läuft und
das heißt wenn ihr auf kontrapunkt eu
geht kommt ihr auf diesen fake server so
ich weiß nicht was die mir jetzt die
ganze zeit nahmen wir sagen wollen der
oder schreibt mir gerade keiner kann
sich mehr so nicken und zwar mit der
cast crafter gerade bei skype ein bild
gesendet was ihr euch jetzt einfach mal
ein blende und zwar hat er mir
geschrieben habe ist das wirklich du und
schickt mir dann so ein bild wo auf
diesem server wirklich hier irgendwo ein
kontrast stand und sich irgendwie als
contractor gelegt hat oder so und dann
meinte dass er die rechte sei und es ich
finds allgemein schon ein bisschen doof
mehr oder weniger ich meine es ist rein
rechtlich gesehen ich weiß ich hab es
rein rechtlich gesehen wirklich verboten
ist ich will mich da nicht hinter
schnellen ich will auch nicht so was
jetzt hier anzeigen oder irgendwie sowas
wieder vielleicht was vielleicht andere
machen würden oder so ich möchte euch
einfach nur sagen freunde
ich meine die leute sind ja denkt auch
ein ganz nett also der ordner hat mir
zumindest ja gar doch geschrieben man
kann sich nicht als konkreter nicken
ich weiß allerdings nicht wem dieser
server wirklich gehört und was das ganze
soll
weil wenn man eigentlich sich in
minecraft server macht dann nennen
ihnen nicht nach einem großen youtuber
dem deshalb ganz gehört kraft davon wo
hast du den server ist doch egal
existiert und zwar mit meinem namen also
event.com in den servermarkt com ag
komplett nennt dann ist es vollkommen
legitim weil es halt sein mehr oder
weniger name ist sag ich mal wenn revier
server macht in rovinj zeitpunkt
nettogewinns zeit.de ich weiß nicht
genau wie der als er den so nennt ist es
natürlich auch vollkommen okay
allerdings wenn ich mit diesem server
nichts zu tun haben und die den einfach
concept.de oder kongress.de ups da
glaube ich nennen dann ist es nicht in
ordnung ok schreib mir gerade ja du
kannst du auf den tisch kommen ich werde
jetzt gleich einfach mal auf den ts
gehen bzw
da einfach mal vorbeischauen ich gar
keine zeit weil wir müssen gleich warum
aufnehmen es ist gerade 20 minuten vor
der offiziellen ersten bahro aufnahme
ich weiß nicht wann ich dieses video
hochladen werde wahrscheinlich am
sonntag und dann haben wir halt schon
die erste folge war aufgenommen die
sache ist allerdings ich wollte euch nur
kurz sagen freunde wenn ihr auf den
server geht oder irgendwas take control
server der erfolg oder kommunalkongress
datenserver und dann legt sich die ganze
zeit wer als kontrast und beleidigt an
oder irgendwie so kriege ich ja immer
die krassesten nachricht da irgendwie
ich habe keinen ts server ich habe
keinen minecraft server ich habe keinen
dies kein dass das dieser server dieser
kontrapunkt zu der gehört nicht mir
jetzt von den welchen leuten einfach
meinen namen benutzen möchte auch
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mit den ordnern
reden vor allem weil ich doch gar nicht
kann weil ich jetzt relativ zeitnah in
die ja ich muss jeden moment los in die
war ots konfi gehen muss und eine kurze
messages videos ist ein sehr kurzes
video was allerdings am herzen lag diese
ganzen faker regen mich auf es gibt es
immer wieder dass ich auf irgendwelchen
crack servern irgendwelche leute
contractor nennen und dann alle
möglichen beleidigen und dann schreibt
mich leute an öl du hast mir letzte
observer beleidigt ich würde nie eine
person auf einem server beleidigung und
schreiben auch du und du kriegst keinen
screen oder irgendwie sowas würde ich
nicht schreiben vor allem ich weiß nicht
mal was dieser server wieder aufgebaut
ist was das hier überhaupt ist irgendwie
naja jedenfalls es ist egal ich möchte
euch einfach nur sagen bitte connect
nicht auf diesen server und wenn ihr
darauf connected dann bringt die nicht
mit mir in verbindung obwohl mein name
einfach steht das war's